[Music]
you know you're born you don't know
where you come from you slip into the
grave 50 60 80 years later you don't
know what that means
and so between birth and the grave where
you are is the world of tongue the world
of time space energy and matter and I
think of it as a kind of a puzzle or a
challenge if you can figure it out you
know your pluck Dolf into some other
dimension with new problems and new
challenges if you can't figure it out
you probably just turn back into a son
being in the field that's the whole
thing
I hope people are sensitizing themselves
to the felt presence of experience
that's what the Dow is that's what the
intuition is an experience of our own
being and tone it's something like going
into dream it's something like taking
the hyper-technical virtual reality
internet head of the snake and inserting
the shamanic late Paleolithic ecstatic
orgiastic tail of the snake and then you
have the aura Borak completion then you
have the quintessence and the work is
complete and history ends and we live
then in the light of the stone made
manifest
there is unimaginable strangeness not at
Sanibel that movie or Proxima Centauri
but you know North Denver phenomenal
weirdness haunts the world nearby and
and you can't find it if you are not
distracted by false weirdness and there
is so much false weirdness these days
that I I feel almost like I'm trying to
save people from the clutches of all
this sudden rage banditry they see about
the core of being is pure contradiction
life is death death is life the past is
the future the present is eternity and
comprehending this is not to become some
kind of ivory tower intellectual
comprehending this is to move past
intellectual concepts to actually
embrace love love is what waits beyond
abandoning the search for closure love
is not pleasure love is the challenge
emotion being in the purest sense not
become this is the realm of becoming and
it is always striving it is always
incomplete love is the realm of true
being and it lies beyond the prison of
culture beyond the prison of ideology
beyond the prison of self defined
limitations thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you